us human beings are such ambitious
creatures we dream of cosmic expansion
we dreamed soar the heavens to transcend
the biological shackles that limit us
and I think one of the most interesting
ways in which we rehearse our own
ambitions in a-- is through the use of
metaphorical entities Greek and Roman
gods being the best example this is a
way for us to safely idealize ourselves
you know this is where we can without
censorship aspire to be and of course by
labeling them gods we don't have to
admit that it's really us who long for
those attributes and qualities of
omniscience and omnipotence whether it's
Bacchus the Roman god of wine and
intoxication or Morpheus
God of Dreams right or Prometheus who
stole the fire from the gods right or
Adam who baked from the Apple the tree
of knowledge you know I mean when you
look at computer companies like Apple
that is a reflection of that Promethean
spirit of stealing fire from the gods
all the world's knowledge and
information stored in the Google
database the literalization of our dream
our psychedelic Promethean dream
find expansion to be as gods you know
having invented the gods we can turn
into them huh this is the human yearning
this is what we want we just come out of
it admit it to ourselves already and go
about actualizing this potentiality
within us to free the brave reckless
God's within us all
you